На сьогоднішній день ми працюємо втрьох.
Це Артем, я та наша вірна помічниця Юлія Сергіївна.
На мені висить відповідальність за те,
щоб продукт був зшитий, щоб знайти більш лаконічні шляхи
для втілення тієї чи іншої ідеї.
Якщо казати про Артема, то його посада
офіційно називається «посіпака».
Насправді я вже приєднався до Blackpack,
коли все було погано.
Бо Саша — дуже така гаряча кров.
Не доліпив і побіг далі пасочки ліпити.
Я трошки по-іншому.
Я намагаюся складати маршрут і його дотримуватися.
Саша шив бананки, меседжери,
рюкзачки простенькі для замовників.
Він відмовився і з'явилася думка, що потрібно робити це.
Бо це — те, що варто робити.
Тому що монотонна така робота на замовників — це гроші.
Але це нудно для нього.
В чому цінність роботи такої в порівнянні з замовниками?
Тут самооцінка, напевно, або проста радість, коли людина
отримує рюкзак і каже: «Це щось космічне, це щось круте».
І це приносить задоволення.
Розумієш, що не дарма почали, не дарма робимо.
Щось вкладаємо, модифікуємо.
Тобто хочеться пишатися тим, що це робиться в Україні.
Що український продукт може бути, не те,
що не гіршим, ніж придуманий кимось в Штатах, в Європі,
і при цьому, в більшості випадків, зшитих в Китаї.
А може бути кращим як за функціоналом,
так і за якістю, можливо і за ціною.
І він створив прототип.
І через те, що відмовився від замовників,
то трішки боргів набрався.
Коли трохи заворушилося,
коли потрошку люди почали брати,
коли ми вже продаємо, шиємо,
коли вже якось все круто...
І тут він мені каже: «Чувак, але одне маленьке "але"».
І от бачите лисину?
[сміється]
Тоді я ще був волосатий.
І я сказав: «Назад дороги немає».
Відступати, коли все закрутилося, вже пізно.
Насправді ми з Артемом товаришуємо, як мінімум спілкуємось,
років з десять. Ми вчилися в одній школі.
Третього січня 2017 року пішов на роботу і думаю:
«Щось хочу, щось хочу, щось хочу зробити круте!».
Тридцятого січня я вже маю перші фотографії цього рюкзака.
Тобто я в нього вліпив все, що хотів.
Все, що вмів, все, що не вмів — то навчився. Зробив.
І от якраз перші замовники сказали:
«Ось тут, ось тут, ось тут і ось тут».
І завдяки цьому в рюкзаку реалізовано декілька ідей,
які я сам своєю головою не зрозумів.
Але завдяки їхнім ідеям вдалося це втілити,
і рюкзак став кращим.
А так, насправді, якщо казати про кількість змін рюкзака,
якщо брати в розрахунок якісь невеликі зміни,
то, напевно, версій до десяти — п'ятнадцяти.
Це остання модифікація, остання доробка цього рюкзака.
Це наш експериментальний зразок.
[сміється]
Ми поспілкувалися з Паблом Ескобаром,
і він каже, що кишень замало не буває.
Каже: що більше кишень, що краще
вони сховані, то краще для його бізнесу.
Тому тут реалізовано багато різних потайничок.
В першу чергу — це рюкзак-сумка з можливістю
змінювати об'єм, і який при цьому ще й розбирається.
В рюкзаку основні речі, ти десь добираєшся,
рюкзак залишаєш десь у номері
чи у хостелі, де тобі зручніше.
А всі інші речі можеш взяти з собою.
Навіть є кишеньки для пляшечки.
Це зручно для автостоперів, наприклад.
— Людей з алкогольною залежністю.
[сміється] Ти зрозумів?
Якраз дивіться: лекало [форма] звідси знято.
Тут насправді з любов'ю до кожного все зроблено.
Тому що завжди, як Саша вже казав, приємно від людей чути:
«Ви зробили мою поїздку фантастичною!»
Перші кроки давалися з великим боєм.
Тому що, по суті, не було нічого. По суті, все спочатку.
Грошей мало того, що їх немає, ще й повинен.
Не бачиш розуміння зі сторони
хоча б тих людей, для яких ти це створюєш.
Але багато чого зіграла підтримка близьких людей.
На першому кроці ми запустили акцію,
напевно, я не знаю як це назвати.
Це було максимально [дешево], напевно,
по собівартості ми їх продавали.
Друзі це все ширили.
І нашкреблось зовсім небагато цих замовників.
Це працює так: ти хочеш віджиматися сто разів зуміти,
але зараз ти не можеш жодного разу.
Але ціль — сто разів.
І щоб до цієї мети дійти, просто потрібно
просту річ робити — віджиматися.
З колінок, наполовину лікті розгинати.
Потім вийде перший раз.
Круто! Але якщо ти не кинеш,
то ти дійдеш до цієї сотні — і це буде мета.
Але в плані свого виробництва,
коли ти думаєш з точки зору вигоди,
що ти хочеш зробити от таку сумку
і заробити на ній мільйон.
То все, провальна тема.
Коли зиск стоїть за ідеєю,
то та ідея не коштує нічого.
Коли ідея стоїть для якоїсь великої цілі,
що ти хочеш цим, що ти будеш робити,
зробити щось добре, світ кращим.
Тоді вона коштує того, щоб жити.
Ми, можливо, будемо першою українською
рюкзачною компанією, яка буде відома на весь світ.
Світовим брендом.
Я думаю, що ми можемо цього досягти.
Хочеться, щоб люди тут, в Україні, мали нагоду
заробляти собі на життя таке, як вони хочуть.
При тому мати улюблену роботу
і приходити казати як тут все класно.
І вони виходять з роботи щасливі,
приходять на роботу щасливі.
Це, напевно, найперша річ, яку хочеться досягти.
Бо людині не потрібно яхти за сто вісімдесят мільйонів доларів.
Досить мати затишний куточок вдома, де тебе чекають.
Мати, якийсь там, звичайний легковий автомобіль.
І хочеться, якось, не чекати якогось чарівника на вертольоті,
який прилетить і цукерками покидає в тебе
і скаже: «Все буде добре, я полетів далі».
Хочеться вже самому робити, бо якщо
ми не зробимо, то не зробить ніхто. Тільки в наших руках.
Коли ми вже нарешті припинемо нити
і казати, що винен кожен, тільки не я,
то тоді, напевно, будемо жити трохи краще.
А ми зі своєї сторони будемо робити
щось те, що ми можемо робити.
І так кожний кубик до кубика і вийде цілісна картина.
Ось і все.